okay so i have a question for the lady
let's say you meet the perfect guy this
guy is handsome rich successful all the
boxes that you want it to be checked
their check now he pays 100 of the bills
so you can do what you want you can work
if you want to work not work if you
don't want to work but he's paying for
everything you're happy like this is the
happiest you've ever been but one day
you get a message from a girl this girl
met him randomly at a bar on one of his
away trip he took her home and slept
with her she provides evidence of
everything it happened but it was just a
one-time thing now you love this guy
this is the happiest you've ever been
and when you confront him about it he
apologizes he admits to it he says he's
very happy in the relationship he loves
you he wants to be with you it was just
a one-time thing now mind you this guy
is a one in a million he can take care
of you the rest of his life do you look
past it and try to work through it or do
you walk away let me know in the
comments